all right guys this is it this is going
to be our first look at black adam the
rock just said
he's going to give us some scenes of the
movie where black adam's first revealed
all right here we go
why the hierarchy of power is about to
change
oh here we go here we go we go very
first look
all right
oh this is
oh the crown
oh
oh
come on
[Laughter]
oh yeah
yeah oh that looks sick
gosh that really is a teaser is there
something after the logo
oh
no way
oh that's awesome
oh that's so sweet okay let me pause
this
oh my gosh that was so sweet that was
just like the tiniest little teaser that
there was when he caught the bullet when
he when he freaking like burnt the guy's
skin all the way down to
the skeleton i think that i really do
think that the rock
is going to make a perfect black atom i
think this is the perfect role for him
and i'm honestly just insanely excited
for this movie i think it's going to be
an incredible movie and one of the most
anticipated movies of 2022 and there's a
lot coming out in 2022 but go ahead let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below what was your first
reaction to our first true black adam
teaser actual footage from the movie let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on all dc news and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof